he's like some imagined parabola that
obeys the same set of geometric bruises
locus then we started with over before
but I put it in a nice convenient spot
okay when the directrix here I've got my
focus here okay now for any point on
this parabola I should be able to save
ruthless at that point there I should be
able to say that the pieces to the focus
and the perpendicular distance to the
directrix they should be the same do you
agree with that okay
now what that should mean is I ought to
be able to construct lessons okay be
back to have preview stopping I ought to
be able to construct a circle with its
center of pain right and the
circumference should pass through let's
see how I go the circumference should
pass through it number one the focus and
number two it should be tangent to the
directrix think about this the balance
it has to be this way because number one
all right if its center is there its
radius over here must be in the
elevators but down here if it's radius
is here and the radius is perpendicular
to the tangent at the point of contact
right then your tangent to the directrix
the directrix will be that tangent does
that make sense so that's right angle
here all right so I'm gonna try and show
this to you now how am I going to get my
how am I gonna get my circle into this
so I get the right set of points okay
well here's the first thing I'm going to
do I want to pick a point somewhere on
here on this line and I want something
to introduce these guys
so have my and what I want is a
perpendicular line okay now think about
this first second I'm imagining where
I'm headed is the very some point on
this line such that the distance
I'm guessing is about there right the
distance here to here and here to here
is the same right so in other words it's
the center of a circle that makes it
okay so you're picturing I have my
tangent down here and I have my
imaginary circle that's not quite there
yet right but where is it going to be
okay so imagine that right now not only
do I have that but I have this
relationship with this point over here
okay now if I construct a line through
there and its midpoint what I've made is
remember I said my imaginary circle is a
center somewhere in here yeah and these
two points are both on the circumference
of myself both on the circumference of
my circle okay so therefore this line
that I have just constructed if there's
a circle going around what kind of white
is this not just made its a chord very
good right see the circle that's there I
can't draw it yet because I don't have a
center to put it under okay but it is
there this is actually what you're doing
so prigioni questions you like this
picture I'm trying to see but you have
to use your imagination right so this is
a chord this is the UM this is the
middle of that chord so i bisected the
chord right now I'm trying to find where
the center of this circle is right I
know this line goes through the setup
okay
but if I could cause I know you use this
property last week in the quiz right
that the perpendicular bisector of this
chord should also pass through the
center right so let's put that pup in
the Gila bisector Ian there we go one
two do you see what's happening
he's the court he is the perpendicular
bisector it must pass through the center
he's a tangent and he's the radius right
it also must pass through the center so
where they both Kauai
that should be the center of the second
great so many point for that okay that's
where I'm guessing now that's not good
enough for me really I'm gonna see if
this really works so let's draw
ourselves a circle BAM there we go okay
so what have I got let me get rid of my
constructions for you okay I don't need
this guy okay so what have I got now
right where do I start from I started
from a point myself focus and I got this
line down here the directrix and I can
move this direction to wherever our life
bracket I'll put it back in a second all
these other points but this sum this
point he now wherever I move is it's
going to be the same distance from the
focus and the directrix you see that
wherever I put it it's maintain that
distance okay just to make a really
really obvious let's do this so you can
see the two distances involved there's
that one and I'll make
and then there's this one and I'll make
him what's a nice visible color green
Thank You blue let's make this one down
here Donna because that's what I wanted
there we go it's actually probably a
koneko all right now
blue and red are the same those are
those two distances right now I can move
this guy around let's let's move him
around you can see that happen you can
see the distance to the maintain they
have to be maintained because of the
circle we made but you see that and this
is okay this is okay but remember I kept
on saying you can either think if the
locus as a set of points like you guys
standing up there or I can say if the
pot that's traced out by a single point
that moves a single point that moves
okay now I could trace so let's have a
look at this thing great okay I'm going
to move around this point and seed
pathetic traces out of what I want to
trace I'm sorry let's undo that trace
the right
okay what I want is that guy that's the
part that one goes out Tracy
okay ready now as I move what's
happening all right these are the easy
points these are the points that on that
people went to when they're like I'm
lazy
hi I want an easy spot but if to measure
up right all of these points it's really
easy to see that it's equidistant right
but as you start to go a bit further
away it starts to curve upwards like
this you see that okay and over here
okay all right now hold on a second you
can see you can see this shape that's
forming right
I have a really fat parabola it see
exactly like the problem we just did
like it's 1 over 12 hey what's up let's
try this again but just trace that guy
okay
put this guy in a bit all right down
what's happening here okay I brought
everything much much closer together
okay so in order to have this distance
preserved as I go further out this way
my points gonna have to get higher watch
you can see it's getting steeper over
there in order to preserve that blue and
red together okay and this starts give
you another estimate when you're doing
it in steps doesn't it but that computer
doesn't have to estimate he can do it
exactly okay so as you're getting that
number that see this distance in key
it's smaller okay this whole shape is
getting steeper do you see that let's do
it one more time
let's move this guy all right what are
we gonna get what do you predict let's
give a shot there we go and that's what
are you steep is it right that's what
you normally think on that's what you
might normally draw when you just say y
equals x squared okay there's that shape
be literally traced out okay so givi you
might spin you back around
oh wait sorry don't leave it leave it
leave it no something I forgot to do
okay we um we got I got us
I've got a stay up the trophy ship which
is like up what if we have the line
going a funny way okay well let's see
what happens now he's my back guy I
don't want to trace for a second okay so
what happens if my line construction
what happens if my light is off it's
some funny angle okay so let's move I'll
do anything
all right so here we go okay so let's
get rid of
all right now what are you expecting
yeah because this thing is only
different from my original illustration
by being offered a bagel right I hope to
expect my same shape often an angle is
my pain I can't get off I go there you
go he's pretty shallow it's pretty
shallow but you will unmistakably get
the same parabola shape it just happens
to be all angle okay now it's worth
mentioning okay because I provided an
equation for you I provided wise was
negative 3 that was at directrix okay
what could be an equation that would
keep you in of the angle like this how
about y equals x that has that kind of
gradient but you can still go through
this whole process
algebraic oh is that thing stopping what
will happen I this is actually a
challenge I'm going to set you right
you're expecting something like this now
that I'm sure this is what it's you're
going to get it's still a parabola but
it's not the kind of problem you've been
working with I'll not let you if you if
you're interested just to pick a line
pick a point consciously we know how to
find each distance right hand we know
how to simplify algebraically see what
you